au nom de toute la famille je veux
d'abord remercier les gens du québec et
des autres nations qui par milliers nous
ont témoigné au cours des derniers jours
leur sympathie leur affection et leur
respect pour papa et son oeuvre
nous en avons tous été très touché vous
nous avez apporté beaucoup de réconfort
et papa on aurait été profondément
heureux on nous demande souvent ce que
c'est que d'être les enfants de bernard
landry
si pas banale bien sûr enfin il nous
racontait des histoires qui nous emmener
au camping solaire nous emmener en
gaspésie comme les autres papas mais pas
vraiment comme tous les autres papas
petit peu de mes amis chanter avec moi
el pueblo unido jamas sera vencido le
peuple uni jamais ne sera vaincu
et j'étais déjà adulte lorsque j'ai
appris que les vraies paroles de la
chanson de nicolas et bart n'était pas
maintenant riel et chénier vous vivez au
fond de nos coeurs peu d'amis aussi
avait un papa qui rouler en citroën ds
en pestant les gitanes en chantant à tue
tête du brassens reliquat de son séjour
en europe
puis il y eut 1976 on se voyait moins
bien sûr mais nous les enfants avons
vécu des moments exceptionnels il nous
emmener partout des assemblées de
cuisine des réunions de militants des
débats avec des adversaires
papa des camps politiques il n'ya pas
d'ennemis il n'y a que des adversaires
des repas animé avec des esprits
brillants aucune porte ne nous était
fermé il tenait à ce que nous soyons
instruits et éduqués
il nous a exposé à sa grande culture à
son amour du français et de la
civilisation qui le portent au respect
de son prochain à son combat sans répit
pour ses idéaux
à une manière d'être citoyen vous
imaginez sûrement ce que c'est qu'être
un ado au restaurant avec son père qui
fait une scène pour être servis en
français
ado c'est très dur mais c'est très
formateur
on apprend que parfois pour changer les
choses il faut monter au front
il faut savoir mener des batailles même
lorsqu'elles ne sont pas populaires
il avait d'ailleurs eu le courage de
redéfinir avec ses collègues du parti
québécois
la notion même de ce qu'est une famille
leur refonte du code civil a permis à ma
soeur julie d'être reconnue comme la
mère des deux enfants qu'elle a eus avec
sa compagne papa était un homme
rigoureux avec tout ce que ça implique
comme ce soir où ma soeur mon frère et
moi nous étions dans la jeune vingtaine
et ils nous avaient vertement engueuler
au souper du dimanche il avait même
quitté la table quand il a su que nous
n'étions pas allés voter aux élections
municipales scolaires
shelly landry les attentes étaient
toujours haute puis verchères là où est
née sa gran paternité avec le baptême de
camille à l'été 87
ma mère et mon père ont ouvert leur
maison grande comme leur coeur avec
chaque nouvel enfant pape a rajouté une
place pour dormir et le grand-papa
chantait des chansons il préparait des
feux de foyer et se laissait maquiller
ils organisaient des feux d'artifice
bonne nuit princes et princesses de la
lièvre et du saint-laurent
voilà comment mon père quittait ses
petits enfants en leur rappelant leurs
racines avant de les envoyer dormir papa
nous mêmes réunis avec cette maison il a
permis à la famille élargie de nouer des
liens qui ne se brise on jamais
puis à table il y eut des chaises vides
nous avons souffert ensemble mais les
repentants repris les vives
conversations aussi les événements
chacun les débats sur l'actualité et
souvenirs de jeunesse les anecdotes de
saint jacques
les blagues il aimait se mettre en scène
et autour de la table de nouveaux
visages ajoutant chacun sa couleur son
histoire son avenir tissé dans le nôtre
nous avons été vraiment choyés avec nous
rapporter papa était très fier de notre
famille métissée serré qui représente ce
que le québec devienne papa est
également très fier d'avoir eu la chance
d'être accompagné par trois femmes
exceptionnelles
sa mère thérèse lorraine notre mère et
notre chère chantal elles sont toutes
les trois certainement une des sources
de sa grandeur lors de notre dernier
souper de famille il a porté un toast le
vent notre verre à la famille
et à la patrie il n'y a rien de plus
important au coeur de sa vie
ces deux thèmes la patrie et la famille
quand on y pense il ne s'agit au fond
que d'un seul il avait la preuve en
fonds de conviction que la patrie et la
famille rassemble toutes les deux des
gens qui partagent une histoire des
valeurs et qui chaque jour décide de la
nouvelle page du livre qu'ils vont
écrire ensemble pour lui à quelque
échelle que ce soit les forts doivent
protéger les faibles
aux échecs et à l'adversité
à quelle que soit l'échelle il faut
vivre ensemble les départs qui nous
attriste et les arrivées qui nous
renforcent notre père est éternel et
vivra toujours dans les gestes les
décisions les combats et les bonheurs de
chantal julie caroline philippe josé
pascal maxime camille gabriel marguerite
clémentine elle si jules robin médéric
matteo flavie sacha nouveau bébé qui
arrivera dans deux mois et tous leurs
descendants en terminant plus que tous
les hommages ce qui le rendrait heureux
c'est que vous tous à votre manière
continuer son combat pour un québec plus
juste plus fort plus libre merci
[Applaudissements]